ضربه قويه لاتلاف لتنيياه الحكومي من
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه التي قررت
باغلبيه عشره قضاه في مقابل معارضه واحد
الغاء تعيين رئيس حزب شيعه سرير درعي
وزيرا في الحكومه بسبب ادانته في قضيه
فساد ما يعني انعل نتنياهو ان يقيله من
منصبه وما يعني ايضا بان الحرب على النظام
القضائي التي تسميها الحكومه اصلاحات
ستستعر ازواج دستوريه وربما
ازمايتيه ولكن مما لا شك فيه هناك ازمه
بين السلطه القضائيه والسلطه التنفيذيه هي
الحكومه في سبب اقاله الوزير همم
اللافته ان قرار المحكمه العليا جاء رغم
قيام وزير العدل الاسرائيلي بعرض خطه
اضعاف القضاء عشيه المداولات في ملف درعي
معتبر تهديدا للنظام القضائي الاسرائيلي
الذي احاكم نتنياهو في ثلاث قضايا فساد
يتجاوزت كل الحدود بالتدخل في قانون اساسي
اقر باغلبيه 63 شخصا عكس رغبه الاغلبيه
للاسف المحكمه العليا تعتقد بانها حاكم
خفي لاسرائيل
تخالف القانون وحكومه لا تلتزم بالقانون
هي حكومه غير قانونيه
الائتلاف سيسرع التشريعات المتعلقه
بالقضاء بهدف محاوله اعاده درع الى منصبه
ومن بينها تغليب قرارات الكنيست على
قرارات القضاء وتامين اغلبيه للسياسيين من
الائتلاف في لجنه تعيين القضاء والغاء
فقره المعقوليه القضائيه كالتي حسمت امر
درعي باعتبار انه غير معقول ان يبقى وزيرا
بعد ايداداته المتكرره بقضايا فساد الملك
المعركه بين التوليفه الحاكمه في اسرائيل
ونظام القضائيه شهدت نقله نوعيه بالغاء
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه توزير درعي
تصب الزيت على نار المواجهه الدائره في
البرلمان وفي الشارع الاسرائيلي ايضا زياد
حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه